[Musique]
on dit que paris manque d'espacé eh bien
nous on dit que c'est pas vrai par
exemple dans le quartier de la rue de
charonne pour être plus précis rue le
peut c'est pas la campagne et pourtant
même dans les caves on trouve des vignes
ou plus exactement un pied de vigne
le voici il est vrai que c'est la cave
d'un bistrot mais c'est son propriétaire
jacques mellac qu'il a fait venir
spécialement de sa campagne viticole
avec un peu de terre du pays
pour lui c'était un souvenir est un rêve
mais les choses ont dépassé ses espoirs
lavigne a prospéré et en huit ans elle
est devenue à elle seule une sorte de
vignobles minier
à tel point que chaque année ici on fait
les vendanges
et comme en bourgogne et bien cela fait
bien sûr pour tous les raisins on a fait
appel à une vigneronne pas rigole mais
elle est bien gironde alors c'est du
bordeaux
[Musique]
la production annuelle n'est pas
considérable ces 9 lite peut même dire
neuf bouteilles autrement dit les gevrey
chambertin les cheval blanc les petrus
les pommard et autres châteaux etc m
à côté du coach aaron c'est de la série
[Musique]
le pressage est terminée reste la
vinification qui finalement ne durera
qu'un an et chaque année lorsque l'on
fait leur école eh bien on vend le cru
de l'année passée
s'il vous plaît vente aux enchères et
premiers crus de sharon pas commencé je
vous rappelle que les bouteilles sont
numérotées comme il le grimpeur gilles
originale à 9 annoncée dans les
bannières qui commence samedi victor
voilà on va commencer la banane et les
six marins présents chez cauet tôt par
cinq ans c'est au profit de persos neige
on dit que c'est un moins un but c'est
un habitué mais en fait personne n'a
voulu nous dire quel goût ça avait
[Musique]